I'd like to give a shout out to the jas
kana organizers because this has been
just an absolute dream I've had the time
of my life and I've never felt this way
before it's so true I owe it all to you
so hi I'm Jacob and I'm here to talk to
you all about community about finding
agency within your own communities and
about maintaining a service-oriented
mindset in your community I'm from
Rockford Illinois for those of you who
don't know Rockford is about an hour and
a half west of Chicago which means that
we're like an hour and a half from
anything we're an hour and a half from
Chicago Milwaukee Madison Quad Cities
and we're yeah it's an interesting place
to be I've got a two-year-old so that's
a constant adventure in my life I'm a
recent homeowner I do things outside of
the JavaScript community and the
development community because yeah don't
we all and I also happen to run a
developer meetup group in rockford there
are about 150 developers about half of
those qualify under the general like web
technologies umbrella so I can't really
talk to you all about community without
talking about my first community
pictured here is my mom and and and my
family on her 65th birthday we bought
her 65 roses because it seems like the
sort of extravagant thing that my father
would have done he passed a couple of
years ago and when I was younger he
taught me all about being of service and
doing small kindnesses for people
without expecting anything in return
because that's just how we make our
lives better we improve our situation by
impressing on to it the the things that
really make it great so think little
things like holding doors for people and
saying please and thank you like you
wouldn't believe how much that improves
your life right and that really that
service-oriented mindset really
continues on today in doing things for
my mother when I was really young my
father I was raised Jewish and my father
taught me about in Judaism we had these
principles these these laws of Sedaka
which roughly translates to charity but
it's really about more than that
and there are there are eight different
levels but the the highest attainment is
being able to serve somebody in order to
give them the tools that they need to
continue on serving themselves making
somebody self-reliant and so that's
really a principle that I've taken to
heart in everything that I do I can't
really talk to you all about community
without talking about a community I
spent 40 plus hours a week with I work
for a small marketing agency called
Quiet like communications or 20 people
strong and four of us are Deb's and we
build client websites for for food
industry or with for bida reset we work
in business-to-business within the food
industry mainly with like food
ingredients manufacturers food equipment
manufacturers things like that and so
the devs acquire light just like build
websites all day and it's pretty great
even though we build a product we're
still in a service-oriented industry
where the client really comes first as
you can see the place that I work really
hires for culture we like to do fun
things in addition to to really learning
about our craft together I can't really
talk to you about community without
telling you a little bit about the
community that I live in I really try
and share my values about community in
the place that I live and I try to do so
in running a meet-up like I said there
are about 150 devs locally at our meetup
we get between 10 and 15 on a good night
so if any of you out there from the
meetup in a small town you know exactly
what I'm talking about Rockford is an
interesting place it has a very proud
past it was a furniture manufacturing
town and then an industrial
manufacturing town and then like a lot
of nothing and then over the last few
decades there's been a lot of racial and
class segregation which has just been
expounded since the market collapsed in
2008 and as such people are really a
pathetic and its really like climbing a
pill to get people to act I put the
slide up here taco bell Rockford's
number one Mexican restaurant a little
tongue-in-cheek because I really do love
the play
that I live and and it this is not
representative of the type of people
that I try and surround myself with
which is really like everybody I talked
to because everybody's got an
interesting story to tell but with such
a social apathy it's really hard
sometimes it's like climbing uphill
pulling teeth to get people to do
anything but I'm really here to talk
about developers developers developers
developers developers developers
developers you guys you all so that
being said how many meetup order
organizers do we have in the audience
just so I can get a awesome people
sitting next to meetup organizers turn
to them and thank them because they do
wonderful things for you I also have to
give a shout-out to the ongoing Twitter
battle between two people whose names I
have totally forgotten that has resulted
in a karaoke kamikaze karaoke
competition between meetup organizers
that was fantastic I'm glad I didn't go
last night so I have a voice today right
here pictured is my co organizer Michael
Hopkins he also happens to be a
co-worker of mine you can follow him on
Twitter here and totally surprised them
because I didn't tell him his Twitter
handle was going in this talk he's
really my better half and if any of you
have a co-organizer you know exactly
what I'm talking about so really what's
what's a meetup really you all are at
jas conf you should know this a meetup
is for me a place that I can have an
outlet professionally because when I
talk to my nan dev friends about what I
do it's like talking to a brick wall
when I talk to other developers they
understand exactly what I'm talking
about i said--that's script hung and it
kept me there until seven o'clock and
i'm just i really want to break
something right now you all know exactly
what that's like I meet up for me is a
place where I can go and I can learn
things from other people that know cool
stuff and hopefully integrate that into
my workflow and its place where I can
share some of the things that I've
learned throughout throughout my time
programming but what makes a good meet
up I would say that it's about the users
period on any of you are a fan of
attire and art you might already know
jen jen Schiffer brings communities of
art and code together in a really
wonderful way and a couple weeks ago was
talking about our code being really
ephemeral and the the thing that's
important in a developer community is
the people not the code the code just
doesn't matter so I would say success is
really in the eye of the beholder if you
have happy people at your meetup you're
going to have a healthy meet up so to
that end or your users staying engaged
that is really what matters most so
where do I fit in all of this how did I
come to to run a meetup and try and
organize communities when I was a kid I
read a lot of sci-fi and I dreamed of
these these gorgeous places these
utopians cities where everything was
beautiful and like everybody had a place
and it was all great and then I grew up
I realized that maybe my expectations
were a bit unrealistic overinflated and
the takeaway from this is that just
because not everybody doesn't abide by
these same utopian ideals doesn't mean
that I can't try and bring some of that
to my day-to-day life when I was younger
I played a lot of music and in playing
music I learned a lot about patience for
others because everybody learns at a
different pace and everybody does things
slightly differently and just because
it's a little bit different some a
little bit slower some a little bit
faster that doesn't make it bad that
makes it you know full of personality
right which is what we seek out of our
communities if everybody were the same
it'd be no fun I learned a lot about
collaboration when I played music
because I played in ensembles and
orchestras I played with my peers from
the time I was like knee high to a duck
until I graduated high school if any of
you out there are musicians or other
collaborative other otherwise
collaborative artists I hope all of you
now that you've seen Steve Kenny's talk
you can really appreciate where I'm
coming from here some of you might say
it's a little bit low-tech but I I would
submit that most of the communities that
were a part of our not
focused so this is really important
everywhere all of the communities that
were part of from our families to the
people we might ride the bus with or
share a car with to our co-workers
regardless of whether they're Deb's are
not communication community patients for
others being of service to others these
are important things everywhere when I
got out of high school I moved to
Chicago and I started working for this
company called the Chicago technology
cooperative and I learned how to build
websites for our clients which were
typically nonprofit organizations one of
my mentors that I met here by the name
of David EADS he also helped found a
place called free geek Chicago if any of
you are familiar with the free geek
organization I heard I yes over there
it's a fantastic place and free geek
Chicago is an autonomous organization
that takes its structure from what they
call the mothership free deke Portland
which was the original foundational
place but it's a place where everybody
can go and they can learn how to tear
apart a computer how to rebuild a
computer how to install some software
and it's a really empowering place
because it really serves a need in the
community there's a lot of people out
there who just can't afford a computer
and so if they can go to this place and
they can learn not just about computers
but about computing in a much larger
sense it's it's really an opportunity
for them and after I think it is now 25
hours of service to this organization
they get to leave with a computer so how
cool this at while I was there I learned
a lot about open source software and
some of these open source ideals that I
think we all tend to take for granted I
read this book called the cathedral and
the bazaar if some of you haven't read
it you really should because it's
incredible it tells the story of how
traditional software development kind of
birthed the open source movement that's
written by a man named eric raymond
who's a self-described open-source
historian and in it eric says that open
source development breaks this bind
talking about the traditional roles that
people inhabit and software
making it easier for tester and
developer to develop a shared
representation to communicate
effectively about it this quote talks
about open source development but it's
relevant in to communication models in
all communities so to this i would say
break down your pre defined role
definitions and serve in the capacity
that you decide if you want to teach
something teach something if you want to
learn something learn something if you
want to participate participate in
whatever way it fits you best and do it
to the best of your ability because
that's really where you shine so given
what you know about my background I
would say now that meetups are a
wonderful way to learn meetups are an
opportunity to teach and meetups are a
chance to become a better version of
ourselves a wonderful way to learn an
opportunity to teach and a chance to
become a better version of ourselves
think about that sounds a lot like open
source but you know in the meat space
it's pretty cool so you know learning we
hope that's what the takeaway is every
time I go to a meetup I leave with
something new and that inspires me to
continue going to the meetups because I
learned something and it's cool and I
get to integrate that into my life
meetups for teaching just because
there's somebody talking about something
at a meetup and that's like the focus of
the meetup doesn't mean that you can't
teach something even as somebody that is
just there participating because when
you're sitting at the table and you're
having a conversation with somebody
whether it's about the topic of the
meetup that night or it's about you know
whatever chances are you're teaching
them something and chances are they're
learning something from you so i would
say that teaching is really about being
involved and about having a conversation
and who feels better after me up I know
like when I leave a meetup I'm just
jazzed about like everything
and similarly with conferences like
there's this like great feeling after a
conference when you're like yeah
javascript all the things and and then
you go back to reality but that doesn't
mean that you didn't take something away
from it and hopefully start to do
something you know maybe a little bit
different do something that you haven't
done before try something out and you
know just have fun with what you do
because it's what you do I think that
self-improvement is really intrinsically
motivating so what do you do every day
sit on Stack Overflow you consult the
docs of MTN you google a lot of stuff
hopefully you're on IRC doing more than
just lurking I'm totally guilty of that
I could make an entire presentation like
way more than 30 minutes with the list
of resources that we have available to
us on line through this technology that
we've created the list really goes on on
and on but wouldn't you rather talk
about it in person when you rather hear
how somebody used a certain tool then oh
hey that tool exists i would say that
our colleagues are a most valuable
resource and their experience is the
most important thing that they have to
offer so remember before how we talked
about user engagement what did your
users need when I so I moved away from
Rockford for a little bit and then I
moved back about three years ago three
and a half years ago and I started going
to meet up in the area and at the time
we had a PHP meet up we had a javascript
meetup there was a dotnet meet up Coco
me too but linux meet up and I tried to
get to as many of those as possible but
I'm really going to focus on PHP and
JavaScript because that's what I use so
I went to these PHP and javascript
meetup sand and they were struggling a
little bit because in a town as you can
imagine with 150 developers or so and
like half of them use web technologies
that's a pool of about 70 people to try
and drag out every month and not
everybody has the time to do that and at
the time that I was starting to attend
meetups in the Rockford area the PHP
group was really lagging behind
the organizer had gotten really busy
with work and had moved out of town and
really kind of just like left it up in
the air and there were maybe three to
five people in average attendance and
the JavaScript group well JavaScript a
scary thing that some people i don't
know why but it was similarly poorly
attended and at the javascript group we
happened to have this this wonderful
personality i don't know if any of you
know Cory Frank you should also follow
him Cory is the kind of person that can
can like riff off the cuff about like
anything javascript and it will sound
interesting and cool and it will be
engaging and and then Corey moved away
and so similarly the JavaScript group
was left without a leader and so Michael
my co-organizer who I showed earlier and
myself we kind of took on these two
groups and we decided that hey we really
needed to combine our focus and our
efforts because we would better serve
our community if we had more resources
at our disposal ie each other so meetups
are really about doing what's best for
your community it's about sharing
interest you know there are overlaps in
all programming technologies and you
know just because a JavaScript
conference doesn't mean I can't talk
about you know PHP or net or whatever
I've talked to so many of you who use
these technologies meetups are about
professional networking and support so
now that we've qualified a meet-up how
do we run one so remember when I was
talking about my co-organizer I keep
mentioning my co-organizer this guy
share the load if you can another
perspective and another set of hands can
really help a lot of meetup organizers I
talked to actually have anywhere from
three to five people that kind of take
up this mantle of bringing good meetup
content to the area and the more people
you have the more you can share the load
and the more consistent your meetup will
be as a result and people love
consistency to run a meetup you need a
code of conduct you all had better know
what this is because you agreed to one
in attending today
so in talking with David EADS a mentor
that I had mentioned before so when he
was organizing freak Chicago for a while
they ran without a code of conduct and
there were situations in which people
felt unsafe and they decided that they
couldn't come back because they just
didn't have any guarantees that they
would be safe there so I'm code of
conduct is really about solving that
problem it's about defining harassment
explicitly and defining consequences for
harassment explicitly because people are
going to be people and not everybody
knows how to act right after
implementing a code of conduct at free
geek Chicago there were many many more
situations obviously we're personalities
conflicted and and people were able to
learn how to act properly among each
other and maintain their presence in
that space because again even if
somebody doesn't know how to act right
doesn't mean they don't have something
valuable to contribute so we really want
to avoid that problem and really nobody
is above reproach so these things this
is a really necessary thing to lead a
meet-up you need space no this kind of
space you need a table and chairs you
need hopefully a projector if you've got
more than a couple people to be able to
share what you're talking about you know
some pizza really helps personally we
have a space that's sponsored by a
business that some of our attendees are
a part of and that's wonderful if you
can get a business to sponsor your
meetup most businesses have conference
rooms with things like a table and
chairs and projectors and some of them
might even be willing to sponsor some
pizza if you don't have an opportunity
for that i would suggest contacting
local universities or colleges if you
have any nearby because they love
learning opportunities that's what's
there about right and chances are
they'll give you plenty of free advice
and they will spread your name like
wildfire and hopefully with you know
students attending universities and
colleges you'll get a couple more people
also I would say that if you're small
enough coffee shop or a brewery or
whatever happens to work go with that
because you do need a space but as you
grow you will notice that you will need
a more defined intentional space for
this I would say you also need internet
I mean how many times have you gone to a
conference or a meetup and the internet
is just crap and you notice it right
away it's the first thing you notice
because you pull out your laptops or
your phone you're like what but when it
works it works and it's great so have
internet at your meetup I would say that
you need some tools specifically shared
calendars and documents are wonderful
you know when you're running a meet-up
and you're trying to have some
consistency it's nice to schedule things
out maybe if you're you know writing a
code of conduct it's nice to be able to
collaborate on that you also should
probably use some social media we build
these tools where we can type something
in or take a picture or whatever and
blast it out to hundreds and thousands
of people and you know so use that to
your advantage don't be afraid to go old
school though because email lists are
something that a lot of people
appreciate I know when I say okay I'm
going to go to this meetup I appreciate
getting an email with the ical
attachment and like putting it on my
calendar then it's everywhere so don't
discount the older technologies
personally we use meetup com because
again it's a business sponsored solution
it's free to a certain point but the the
paid version does extra stuff I think
it's by no means an end-all be-all
solution but it does a lot of these
things pretty well and it works for me
so take that with a grain of salt there
might be some potential detractors like
I've heard things heard some negativity
about recruiters finding out about
meetups and then coming to like suck the
life out of your meetup because they
don't really recruiters don't really
seek to contribute they just want to
pull resource right and you ideally
don't want that at your meetup
so in keeping it going remember to focus
on your users it's all about the users
all the time if you're serving your
users if you're engaging your users if
you're keeping them happy they will keep
coming back they will bring people back
and your meetup will grow and don't be
afraid to do something different our
industry is no stranger to this concept
of pivoting some of us in like the most
radical obscene ways and this is really
about a tactic for topics not the
entirety of a meetup I wouldn't suggest
pivoting from like JavaScript to fortran
you know it might not work but for a
while Michael and I were coming up with
after we had combined efforts we were
coming up with topics and after a couple
months that gets exhausting it's really
difficult to come up with content month
after month after month and that's not
to say that we hadn't accomplished
anything that month but you know we're
busy people we have lives outside of
this text stuff and we want to be able
to participate in them so we started
doing these geek dinners and it was
fantastic for a little while because
everybody was like hey let's go to this
brewery and we'll eat some good food and
drink some good beer and it'll be like
great it'll be awesome and then like
after a few months of that we kind of
got in a rut and realized that it wasn't
working so don't do that maybe like once
a year twice at max but I would schedule
it separately from the traditional
meetup format because people don't want
to go to a meetup to just like go to
dinner with a bunch of people like it's
cool to talk shop every once in a while
but people really crave new things at
amita people really crave ideas and when
you're talking about technology in
specific ways those ideas tend to flow
so I think our last geek dinner was like
three people showed up it was abysmal it
was really terrible and and this was
after we had gone through all the effort
of you know combining our two meet ups
to to this Rockford web devs thing and
we were starting to reengage people and
it was going really well and it felt
like we had fallen off of a cliff excuse
me
so then we decided that we were going to
build something collaboratively as a
group we put it up on github it's at
github com / Rockford web / paste bin
too I think they wanted to name it v7
underscore final dash dash but you know
that fell through so over the course of
like six or seven months we
collaboratively built a paste bin clone
and we basically just went to the group
and every other month Michael and I
would switch off coding while we
solicited input from everybody we're
like so we want to build this thing what
would be the first step and we like went
through this whole creative process
together taking input so that everybody
felt like they had something to offer
they felt like they were engaged by this
process and they really contributed some
of them even contributed after hours and
like made commits to the github which
was great you know that's what it's for
so through this project we've
essentially tripled our engagement for
us that means we're up to a steady 12 to
15 on a good night like 20-25 but when
you think about that in terms of the
overall community size talking about a
pool of like 70 web technologies
developers you know that that is pretty
fantastic it has been for us anyway so
really don't be afraid to do something
different and I would say also that you
should use your resources at hand and by
this I mean human resources from the
most personal the ones you're in contact
with every day to those that are semi
local regional or even like if you're a
java or j s conf and you're like hey
would you maybe want to talk at my meet
up and somebody might say yes you know
you never know i would say talk to your
friends be like hey i know you're not
really into this whole development thing
but could you like show up because
having warm bodies in the room means
that people will perceive it as being a
successful thing where people share and
integrate and it works i mean for a
little bit while it really helps to
boost attendance and they might learn
something i hope they would don't be
afraid to talk to your co-workers and
say hey there's this meetup thing that
I'm
doing and you should really come because
it's totally relevant to what we do
every day but do that with some caution
because remember that not everybody has
time to commit to a meetup and that's
okay so don't harass them about it
please talk to your fellow meetup
attendees if you see somebody that's
their week or a month after month and
they just sit and patiently observe ask
them if they would like to share
something that they've learned I know
that for me when I am in that mode where
I'm just like observing I don't often
think that I have something relevant to
contribute but things that might seem
totally mundane to me are maybe
mind-blowing to the rest of you and vice
versa like that's how this community
works so if you help somebody else get
out of their shell they will repay you
with the the most amazing talk you've
ever heard don't be afraid to go to
regional meetups you know it's not too
big of a deal for a lot of people to
jump in the car drive an hour hour and a
half if you don't have access to a car
don't feel bad about that but you know
if you if you look like within a 50-mile
radius of where you're at chances are
there's other meetups around and even if
they're not directly related to the
technology stack that you happen to be a
super big fan of like chances are you'll
learn something there and at those
places you can interact with people who
might be able to bring something back to
your meet up and say hey you know check
this out you come and visit us you know
maybe share something I have to give a
shout out to the Madison PHP user group
who has been especially helpful to us
yeah they've been great and most
importantly I mean this to say be of
service to each other this this
particular phrase be excellent to each
other has had some some terrible
failings in our industry unfortunately
hence the talk about codes of conduct
and why that's important but if you if
you maintain a service-oriented mindset
then you know that's really what it's
about we're here to help each other it's
how we grow it's how we learn so i
really hope I've helped to impart a
thing or two about community here today
remember to be of service to your users
above all without users there is no meet
up period so do what they want to a
point know that you have complete
control over your participation I was
talking about open source software
redefining role definitions you know
really do what you want within the realm
that you want do your best at it and and
it will be a wonderful thing and don't
be afraid to do something drastically
different the results will surprise you
thank you
you